the girag an experienced man it when I
when I I used to make it taste good but
now I don't even make this scale shake
chase good anymore no I'm a slam it I
just I make it taste coffee horrible
because I give it giant chunks of ginger
and garlic now okay i'll have like a
like serious like remember what pages
used to look like yeah yeah paint your
last chunk of gin just fucking hammer it
in one shake oh but that's in one shake
you slam that no ginger Oh fam I'm like
that turtle I've have about half of that
in a week shake oh really yeah no I slam
it slam it and four or five cloves of
garlic getting on quite smells so bad
afterwards well boy I i got my garlic
intake for sure good look a yoke man I
smell it share you like garlic she's
just train ya know just uh just ate some
garlic your loads yeah come orrible I
don't know oh let me know next time
you're in a steamy on it you'll be all
right right next time you today takes a
minute a test and mood this make a video
good probably a lot of YouTube forms
blah ya know if you just all you'd have
to do is just I would come on the desk
and just dip your finger oh my god and
go like that that's all you would have
to do no that's it would be ng I guess
it's over it's over that's what you you
two would break I'm sure you got the
curdled kind where you could just pick
up no my loads are very normal turtle
time this shit took attract you a lot of
water dude oh that's true water really
healthy my loads of quite fluid tastes
like garlic and this is like back at the
academy my alpha male crew right here
imagine if dude we're like chicks where
I was women have a certain amount of
eggs and then that's it it's over
imagine if dudes were like that we have
a certain amount of odds you know and go
see you like checking you look up hold
your balls up the Sun see like where
your load line is no charge a lot of
people that way so did a lot of people
that have blue balls that's for sure
yeah I can't get can just go pay my loan
this have the worst halo next day girls
be like come on give me some loan
worth it you know I should become it's
like a gambling a rational thing guys
would go and go to trickle they'd go
tantric we squeeze it down never really
orgasm if that was a tip your dick and
like a lighter oh if that was a case if
that was the case guys would have more
power and getting laid there it's true
that on the girls side of it you know
like it's easy for easier for a girl
it'd be a whole lot easier for a guy if
you only had so many listen if we all
fucking band together we can make a
strong are you hearing right this yes
does it start this right now it's a
podcast podcast is powerful yeah it's
have a dick union yeah it's hella right
here yeah take back your loads save them
you know George important they're not a
valued right now in the equation but
dammit they should be stop wasting them
the game radiant the key ingredient in
making people oh man without the loads
you got nothing that's the problem
though it's like that would be like
starting a fighters Union like that's
not really gonna happen you know but
dudes like fuck them yeah that's that's
what dudes would say when it comes to
the dick Union if we all got together
and said listen we're gonna we're gonna
we need to make our dicks more valuable
okay we need to make it harder to get to
let's work something out here boys the
first ones are gonna sacrifice big time
and the ones that are starting this
thing because now they're the only ones
not getting laid you start this whole
trend you know same as with the fighter
union you only one not getting paid I
think you're right though it is really
target it's hard it's easy to say oh the
voters are lazy or whatever they should
be honestly like you say they got real
lives to live and they haven't got time
for all this stuff and that is a really
big part of why we want to make it
simple you know we're assuming that
people want to spend less time doing
this stuff not more time right and I
think a lot of the kind of organizations
and people that have tried to get people
you know mobilized you know civic
organization and kind of that kind of
thing you know it's worked to a certain
extent with some people but for the
majority of people they just don't want
to do it they they can't do it actually
they're literally too busy with things
that are higher priorities like their
kids in their family and their job or
whatever it may be hobbies doesn't
matter it's stuff that they choose to do
and that's fine that's their life and we
shouldn't kind of require that you
have to spend ages figuring out this
political stuff and that's why we're
trying to make it really simple for
people but based on quite a lot of
complex what technology allows you to do
you can take quite a lot of complex data
and information like we're doing with
the campaign finance records where it's
literally hundreds of millions of pieces
of information and we're boiling it down
into one piece of information which is a
score like where is this candidate on
the on their scale of liberal to
conservative whether they sit and where
are they on each issue that's what we're
trying to do to make it really simple
isn't it sort of analogous and a way to
what we were talking about about the
amount of people that you can keep in
your brain Dunbar's number yeah is that
if you lived in a small tribe if safe we
all live 50 of us together in some small
village somewhere we really wouldn't
have votes about gay marriage and we
really wouldn't have ghosts about
exactly there's be a million different
things that would never be up for vote
and if someone really did start
micromanaging everyone's lives you be
like hey you know mike is an asshole we
gotta kick him out of this fucking tribe
this guy's trying to get people to wear
purple and you know where certain Nikes
during different moon cycles and make
tribal rules and rituals and make all
these things standard and you know for
whatever reason he doesn't like men
sleeping with men like he's got some
weird thing you know he believes it's
part of so true I just so agree with
that one of my favorite things that I'm
one of the these experiments that
happened was in Holland I think I'll get
that right um in Europe and they did
this brilliant experiment with traffic
where they in a town I think it was
friesland or something like that
probably got that wrong where they
literally took away all the traffic
signals all of them everything right
they took away traffic lights they even
took it we know stop signs everything
even though the markings on the road so
they took away the white line in the
middle of the road everything all gone
and their theory was that without that
kind of external rule making and kind of
stuff going on to tell you what to do
people would have to kind of relate to
each other as other people and just
figure it out amongst themselves so
they would you know have to sort of look
other people in the eye and and sort of
work it out between them and they found
they had this brilliant effect which was
that accidents fell 20 the traffic
improved the traffic speed was lower but
the traffic flow was much better it just
worked all around all the kind of things
that you try and do when all these
people thinking about traffic planning
and whatever they achieved all those
aims by literally taking everything away
and just allowing people to relate to
each other as humans and Earth family
rules I thought it's such a great little
story and I think that you could do that
in all sorts of areas if you just leave
it to people to figure out on a small
scale where they can relate to each
other you just get a much better result